this is Little Dipper it's just little
Oh me
why have we given up of that voice so
not the voice he would have I was doing
a little Gideon but earlier was um mr.
bill little mr. bill um I'll get down in
his pants um princess so uh message in
this one was the invisible wizard is
watching um which was like I think you
pointed out something with you there was
a great opportunity they miss like I
mean it was cute where she's like always
it in visit he's like you have to say
some serious fun I was like it would
have been way funnier at least in my
opinion if he's like now there's no
invisible wizard and she opens it and
there's a wizard wizard yeah it's like
oh this is just a giant coincidence
really this is not result of a wizard
well there actually is a wizard there
but it has nothing to do with a like
because I was just waiting for it it was
like please be a wizard in there please
be with no what the great they was
sealed up for it the greatest thing I
think the funniest thing would be if you
want the future episodes like there is
it is Wiz wizard that comes out of the
cloth like a preemie goes you killed the
invisible sword yeah oh shut up so this
one different finds out that Mabel is a
was it a millimeter
yeah millimeter and only works if you're
in Canada this is just you're only
taller in Canada yeah Oh joke and so he
finds this crystal that can make people
bigger or smaller and he puts out a
flashlight which I love I get a great
set of using the flashlight me people
grow bigger smaller it's like a growth
saber yeah sure and they start messing
around with it and gideon gets his hands
on it shrinks a dipper and mabel and now
they have to stop him from taking over
the shack and at the end tickling wins
the day as it usually does and quinn
census and Gideon vows to get revenge on
them once again um I like the fight we
turn a little bit to him having the book
you know yeah and a little bit more to
that because last time we saw him like
he was dressed as like you
like the Pioneer Day or something like
that throwing tomatoes at stab that is
kind of like okay if I was like wait am
i went up to the big revenge and
everything so we we get that back here
yeah I I think this was a good episode I
don't quite know what to think about it
I thought there'd be more with the
mystery with the book and little Gideon
coming back because he has book too you
know I'm just so maybe I just so maybe I
just thought there would be like a
little more development on that front
but I'm just gonna say it like you know
that the episode it is okay it's it's
still decent stuff that's like I hate
shrink episodes I hate episodes were
somebody's small and they have to get
around it cuz they're never funny and
they're never that interesting it's like
oh no you're small now everything seems
big yes and there's like no cool really
a couple of really good moment like I
like seeing the inside of Gideon's
pocket yeah it's partially hair it's
though like I did like I did like him
feeding the giant gummy bear to Mabel
yeah it doesn't get really funny until
about like maybe halfway through and
they bring out the it brings out the
gerbil he has the folks in like cells
and then declares his victory or hums
off I do like the giant caterpillar to
that crush the cars the cars going up oh
yeah in my opinion there is one major
laughs at the very end which I told you
about I had actually paused it the first
time I do it
that's when they're tickling him and
Stan's does I don't know how to react to
this let me you should run your plans
across your friends you know do a little
workshop they still ending awkward sight
I just goes okay here we go any
characters about with us toys before you
onto the garbin air alright here we go
that are okay it was it was so funny as
I'm kicking him enrolling him it's such
a great kid it's such a stand thing to
do just just roll the ball with his foot
um and yeah and there's a strange enough
when Zeus comes in with when he gets
rung it down that's sort where it gets
really funny too because him strung it
down was pretty funny yeah
oh there is definitely something
different here
and I like they destroy the crystal and
then they look they see Susan out helps
loose you lots of glue so um you know
and again I think with this one we were
talking about sort of the obvious morals
and so this one like they literally say
the more high yeah this was not to if
usually not have yet this was not a
brilliant execute only you didn't bicker
so the last few have been really good
this I mean they can't all be perfect so
yeah you know and the height thing is
fun and that's definitely a sibling
thing argue about height and stuff um
but yes Gideon what a creeper I I think
he's a great here something about it was
really funny and intimidating he's funny
intimidating and just so odd I'm just
like well he's like the way know why
it's just little old me
he served like a mix between those uh
those beauty pageant kids and like those
sham ministers acclaim they can hear
what are you in a second I'm my lane my
archenemy's entire family look when he
says it with that little southern drawl
it's like we don't mean I think and the
other thing too I can't remember if we
saw her before but the the mother gets a
Gideon's mother gets a little bit more
attention I think that's like something
out of American Beauty yeah it's your
neighbor's mother yeah they do a few
things with her and they never go quite
too far they always keep it just that
right distance where it's like you're
not quite sure what's going to keep
vacuuming just a vacuuming just know
she's miserable and uncomfortable as
Jake so know how I know this wasn't as a
plot intensive great episode I can
actually remember a number of the lines
because normally I'm so distracted by
everything else that's going on with the
with the story that I have trouble
remembering the lines but this one I'm
like coughing them up like crazy and so
were you yeah and I can't wait like the
more you remember the lines of this one
and in the show actually yeah this your
answer the answer a lot of wines my
guess is I'm not as invested in the
actual story yeah cuz the others it's
like there's so many good lines and so
many good scenes uh that is kind of
weird like a good good episode yeah it's
still good you know like I said just I
never as soon as I saw like you know
Gideon shrink them down I'm just like oh
here we go but it's even
it's really not that bad it's you know I
I just never found the whole big
shrink-down thing that interesting I
even know how you guys like the kids
it's like no no it's like the the
grown-ups are more fun and the sets are
cool like the actual let's go and add oh
but auntie auntie who cares and you have
no heart you hate waddles you hate
auntie you code all ragers great and
small okay all creatures big and small
all creatures big and small are a boy to
you aren't they
I don't hate them they're just kind of
dull um they are it just are but the
giant cookie was cool yes cuz I want
that cookie even today I'm just like oh
my god I want that cookie okay get some
cookies
let's get some little Debbie's let's do
it